our next guest is a very fine gentleman
who actually yeah he's he's he's done
some big things he's taken undercover
journalism with new media to a whole new
level you probably know him from the
Acorn scandal basically got acorn
federally defunded protege of andrew
breitbart and now has a new story to
tell us about project Veritas calm is
his website James O'Keefe thanks for
being on brother
so you're it's you're at CPAC in DC
right now right I am I'm sitting on the
balcony at the Gaylord hotel here to the
Bram until Saturday we're focused on
recruiting undercover videographers try
and find some people to do that here and
at what point do you feel the need to
shoot yourself in the face when you're
Veritas I have a 24-hour rule about
Washington DC I get in here and I get
out within 24 hours just because it's
you know there are some good people here
but for the most part Washington is a
city of lobbyists and people who don't
really do a whole lot and you know hang
on to what other people do so half of
those lobbyists are at CPAC that's a
thing you know I I'm a conservative but
I emceed CPAC for four years and a
certain point I just said ah like you
know the incestuous relationships yes
just don't work for me there's no need
there's no need to network because
you're already networked into all the
people now they're just sort of
gossiping about each other but you know
it's still good because you and me and
other media personalities to have the
audience fans your fans are there and
it's good to get some face time for the
huntin I don't know I don't know I you
know I see the fan I do stand-up a lot
so you know I get to see the fans enough
and then at CPAC it's just awkward and
I'm grateful for every single fan but
it's CPEC is like you walk through the
ballroom and everyone wants to you know
and then they want to ask you questions
and they want you know their podcast
what's like three listeners and if you
say no then they tell you that you're a
sellout so I I just try and avoid it but
James so you've got actually it was was
it New York Post that covered your story
here yes the New York Post on Tuesday
and you know politics is down student
from culture like Andrew Breitbart
taught us and politics is also local and
in New York we got covered by every
single with NBC News CBS News Fox 5 News
and sharpen an MSNBC word is that MSNBC
is about to fire al Sharpton know after
our video expose of them wow I did not
know that so that's well give it give
the audience people who don't know I
know that you did this on al Sharpton
you interviewed people
kasia's for nothing but the chokehold
victim Eric garner yeah I'm like it's
not Gosnell Eric garner because that
happened and Mike Brown and Ferguson
happened so it's tough to keep them all
all straight
but you interviewed some people directly
involved with that people who are
directly involved with some of these
victims that you know conservatives for
a long time have accused the left of of
race baiting and creating division and
some of the people you interviewed said
as much about Sharpton and even more
damning said he would show up pretty
much collect the check and pass go right
yeah Eric garner who's the daughter of
Eric garner he's the guy in Staten
Island who the NYPD did the chokehold on
the alleged so-called right if you look
at this video it's very powerful you can
see the pain the hurt in her face when
she's describing how Al Sharpton's the
National Action Network took advantage
of her and fired what his logos on her
flyers and you know she said look it's
not about the money it's about my father
it's very powerful stuff other
african-american leaders across the
country all saying the same thing all
saying that that they were you know Al
Sharpton's about money he's a shakedown
artist Michael Browns attorney said it's
about money Trayvon Martin's father said
he's on his own mission and usually with
these types of undercover stings I sting
the people I'm filming this case I'm
allowing them to be honest because as
some of them were pretty afraid to say
these things on the record about I'll
sharpen right well that's a great
example you know the left obviously
their criticism of you is it's got you
journalism and I think we're being
honest sometimes I mean yeah you are
trying to get a moment but in this case
you weren't stinging al Sharpton it was
letting people speak and express honest
opinions which are just really damning
about someone else really you know al
Sharpton they weren't damning themselves
on camera unlike you know Sherrod or
some of the people at the Acorn who you
would interviewed they were really just
speaking openly about Al Sharpton
because I
you know I bet you at one point correct
me if I'm wrong cuz you spoke with them
at greater length and obviously we've
seen the clips I bet you at one point
they were hopeful that when Sharpton was
coming in he was going to really help
right yeah I mean well these are huge
tragedies like a focal point in our
social in our civil rights movement in
this country of racial issues continue
to be at the top of you know
unfortunately our the focus of our
politics right now so al Sharpton like
today or yet yesterday was invited back
to the White House this guy is very
close to Obama very close to Eric Holder
and he apparently pays people off he
said he paid for the funerals and this
is truly remarkable within 24 hours
after we exposed this there was a
foundation started
al Sharpton started a foundation with
Erika governor now that's pretty amazing
yeah so he he must write people checks
buy people off and not pay taxes on
whatever taxes was he four million
dollars in back taxes now at four
million dollars visit the White House 80
times how does that happen how does that
happen I am paranoid that you know I I
pay Jared to go out and get me a David
Bowie wig for a parody and I don't have
it listed on expenditures how do you get
to four million dollars in back taxes I
got four lawyers for veritas I got one
IRS compliance lawyer I got one New York
state you know unemployment insurance
lawyer I've got a guy on staff just to
make sure I'm complying with every
single regulation there's lord knows you
and I have the IRS you know constantly
talking about us but I think it's
arrogance and avarice they just they
just are so they're the guys in the
white house why is he worried about the
IRS you know condemning him it's just
arrogance when I hear avarice you know
what I think of fun dip I think if we're
Marley and Marley avarice and greed
remember that the Muppet Christmas Carol
the Marley brothers the hecklers oh yeah
we took advantage of the poor we just
ignored the needy back to James O'Keefe
and serious talk so
do you see Muppet Christmas Carol James
please tell me this I have not seen oh
gosh how dare you it's been out for two
and a half decades you had the time it's
true you watch more movies as opposed to
making them thank you yeah
no really you're making videos but so so
this is what happened right with New
York Post Al Sharpton now you just said
that it looks like he might be fired
from his show firstly I'm kind of
surprised that this is what it takes to
be fired from MSNBC I mean if the four
million dollars in back taxes there's
been a lot of dirt on al Sharpton for a
while where are you hearing this and why
do you think this has been the catalyst
for him
maybe being fired I'm pulling up the
article right now this is on the UK
Daily Mail okay or did yesterday
afternoon al Sharpton this is the
headline al Sharpton to get the bullet
and they talked about his problems as
controversial issues you know this week
Sharpton was also who's also sued by
Comcast for twenty billion dollars so
there's that issue there's this issue
now what was the twenty billion dollars
I've read that and I thought now this
this has to be a typo it must be million
how does an individual get sued for
twenty billion that's usually a lawsuit
against the federal government or
something like that well apparently
there was some type of issue
I don't like try to pull it up right now
because it does sound a little odd
doesn't it twenty twenty billion yeah
I've got in front of me yeah it is it is
a lawsuit for twenty billion I was just
thinking I mean you have to have not
either it's more of a symbolic lawsuit
you know where that no one's expecting
at twenty billion dollars from Al
Sharpton or you have to have committed
something monumentally illegal well
there's an article that Byron Allen
unloads on Sharpton Allen told that tot
meet the interests are actively freezing
out and destroying black-owned media
companies and they're paying MSNBC host
al Sharpton to give them racial cover to
do it so Comcast is a very large
corporation if this is true that al
Sharpton is is being paid to give them
racial cover to destroy black owned
media companies that that is a twenty
billion dollar in damages issue so there
you have it
I think Stevie the combination of this
issue and black african-american victims
daughters of the tragedies speaking out
about it right that's a pretty powerful
week in media against you and and
Sharpton probably is getting a lot of
pressure than the higher-ups and you
know we'll see what happens I can
imagine it's funny you know I remember
him back when he was just goofy old al
who did a few rhymes and appeared in
Little Nicky nearly oh you know he's
he's relatively benign but when you
actually look at the profiteering the
the creating of racial division not
because he's not very respected by many
in the in the black community but there
are some who do and he uses that pulpit
genuinely for evil sometimes to
genuinely create just a racial division
in America wider than it's ever needed
to be in modern America you know we just
go ahead sources we talked to in
Missouri this is in Ferguson Missouri
expressed fear even speaking out about
public right and I didn't put that in
the video because I don't want to make
the guide fear for his long life but you
know that's how people feel about this
guy I don't I mean you know and I get
asked well I don't know if you ever get
this question I get asked this all the
time is should I fear for my life and
most of the time the answer is no I
don't really think about that stuff I
don't I'm a Christian I don't worry
about it but sometimes in this weekend
for some reasons I can't get into I did
get a little scared
sure and I tweeted it out you know
thinking okay well Twitter I'll tell my
fans I know look I'm human I have a
conscience sometimes I'm scared and it
got blown up you know I got LaBrie was
hyped it up James Koepp is you know
afraid of his life sure but this type of
work you know sometimes look the places
we go to get the story sometimes you got
to go in places there are dare dangerous
you know to talk to people who are
dangerous and and sometimes it's an
issue people don't want to speak on the
record about it and they yeah they have
reason to be scared
well I have reason to be scared for my
life namely because I dressed up like
Mohammed and performed a Three Stooges
routine beating the crap out of my
six-year-old wife so they don't have a
great sense of humor about that but I
think you're doing great work here James
if people want to see these videos or
more of you where should they go
Project Veritas Tom
ERI TAS and if you're at the CPAC
conference we're having an event tonight
at 8:00 p.m. to midnight in the hotel
focused on recruitment if you want to be
a undercover person send me a note on
the website we'll try to get you trained
and bedded and maybe going out there
doing this well there you go folks not
only doing great work but helping others
to do the same James thanks for coming
on and we'll definitely have you back on
any time you break a story brother if
you like this video be sure to subscribe
or see my latest videos and if you don't
I'll be upset and trust me you haven't
seen me very upset